hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the version of
hedonistic moral theory that we call
Epicureanism there is a very important
distinction that is made between
pleasures of the body and pleasures of
the mind now I do want to say something
here to clear up any confusions the
Epicureans were materialists so they
don't believe that there's something
like a soul that's separate from the
body or a mind that is that is separate
from the body they believe that both
body in the sense of what we have right
here in mind are things that are
material when you look at their their
actual physical theory about that it's
not very plausible now they thought that
the mind was essentially located in the
chest and that it was it consisted of
these very very tiny very fine particles
spread throughout the entire bodily
system unlike the the parts of the body
which could be separated off and you
know died afterwards cut off a finger
the mind is diffused through the
entirety of the frame so if we put that
that sort of worry aside we could think
about it today in terms still of you
know things that are primarily about the
body like eating drinking having sex
getting a massage laying in the Sun
sorts of things and then pleasures that
really are mental pleasures we would say
you know things that are concerned with
the brain and we're not just thinking
about pleasures but also about their
their opposites pains remember to as I
put it out in another core concept video
there are more than one kind of pleasure
for the Epicureans there's the static
pleasures and then the kinetic or moving
pleasures but we're going to just deal
with them all in the same way here now
there's a contrast that's being made
here that's different from the other
hedonist particularly it's the SI
remaining school the the Syriac school
following air stiffest said that bodily
pleasures are really where it's at that
they're more intense they're there in
some respects more real than the things
that we call mental or intellectual or
however you want to put them spiritual
whatever kinds of players
Epicurus took the other position and he
provides some sort of arguments or
grounds for why that would be so let's
look at the distinction here one major
point of contrast has to do with what we
call temporality time right if you think
about the nature of bodily pleasures
they are completely time-bound while
you're feeling them while you're
experiencing them while you're enjoying
them so a great example is drinking in a
cup of cold water after going out and
doing some yard work on a hot day all
right
you drink the water that pleasure is
very intense at that moment that's
actually sort of a pleasure that's
derived by getting rid of a pain that
pleasures is very intense but it's very
short lasting as soon as you have some
some you know satisfaction and if the
water doesn't even really taste the same
the water tastes better when you're
really thirsty then just a few minutes
afterwards there's the same thing with a
lot of foods you know the first bite the
first couple bites of a dessert great as
it goes on there's a little bit of a you
know lack the kind of insipidity to it
and you know you can only keep tasting
the dessert so long as your taste
spuds are working I mean I suppose you
could like create some sort of gum or
sticky thing that you can put on your
tongue and taste chocolate all day long
but then you wouldn't be able to talk
things like that suppose you could find
some way to stimulate those neurons
inside the brain but then you know
you're doing you're not actually
enjoying the thing bodily you're
stimulating the mind and we'll get to
that in just a moment consider other
players you know there's this really
famous passage in Henry Miller I forget
which book it is where he's talking
about well why don't we just like you
know why don't we just take it easy all
the time why did we work and he said
well you know it's really the only thing
that we can do for eight hours a day
there's a hell of a lot of stuff that's
much more you know entertaining that for
Henry Miller of course it was having sex
but you can't have sex for eight hours a
day I mean if you if you can then I
suppose that would turn into a job then
and so work is the only thing he says
that we can actually stand to do for
that one but he's on to something
you know you cannot have the same
enjoyment the same you know intensity of
bodily pleasure very long lasting for
most of the things that we conceptualize
as bodily pleasures the things that we
experience as bodily pleasures so they
exist in the present time you experience
it right now and then it's gone now it
no longer exists as such just like the
present moment is gone here's where the
mind shows its superiority over the body
according to Epicurus mental pleasures
do occur in a presence but that present
can extend itself through time how does
that happen well remember things
remember the pleasure that you had at a
certain time you can even take a bodily
pleasure that you've experienced and
then by bringing it into memory you sort
of reactivate it's not quite the same as
a you know intense bodily pleasure for
things that actually are mental
pleasures in another own right it's just
as intense perhaps even more so when you
remember it when you contemplate it when
you think upon it why do you imagine it
we also project ourselves into the
future by hoping by fear when it comes
to pains oh god I hope I don't get
cancer really what do you say I hope I
don't get cancer you're saying I'm
afraid of getting cancer right and what
are you afraid of Epicurus would say
well you're afraid of all those things
that are gonna go along with it so when
you're worrying that is actually a
mental pain according to Epicurus that
is you know much worse than a physical
pain because the physical pain just
happens at a present time and then it's
go on right but if you remember the pain
if you project ahead about the pain if
you're dwelling on it that can be much
worse
so some mental pleasures and pains have
a much greater potential for you know
being greater in a number of respects
one is in terms of temporalities nothing
has to do with intensity itself so
Epicurus says that physical pleasures
and pains you can have one or the other
with them they can either be intense
or they can be long-lasting but you
can't have both if you've got a pain and
it's long lasting after a while it
doesn't bother you quite so much it kind
of gets doubled over over time there's
there's a you know a natural thing to
this for our bodies things that we
originally find quite painful ceased to
be so not just by habituation but
because you know we can only be
stimulated so much same thing with
pleasure too you know people can
actually ruin themselves for
experiencing certain levels of pleasure
by having so much physical pleasure you
just can't have that much intensity and
duration at the same time you can
however with mental pleasures
according to Epicurus mental pleasures
and pains can be both long lasting and
intense you know he uses primarily
examples of Ping's but we can also think
of pleasures as well particularly
particularly for thinking about the
static pleasures that are derived by a
condition of rest and freedom from pain
from fear from worry from trouble
but if we're thinking about mental pains
thinking about the sorts of things that
happen to people that have made a really
tragic stupid horrible decision that
they have to live with the rest of their
life that can be quite intense and that
can go on for a very very long time
until they figure out some way to you
know forgive themselves or be absolved
of that or you know learn how to forget
what's going on whereas you know with
physical pains that's not really the
case
same thing with mental pleasures they
can be very intense and they can
increase over time what else do we need
to say about this so Epicurus also says
physical pleasures cannot really be
accumulated as different physical
pleasures so think to yourself you know
he's not telling us an awful lot in the
passages where he brings us up but think
to yourself about going out for a really
nice dinner they have a restaurant where
are things you know there's a lot of
attention to detail and to planning as
far as the meal you know multi-course
meal with a beautiful setting you know
maybe there's some music going on at the
same time there's a certain ambience
that's created epicurus says well you
can only get so far with that you know
when it comes to cuisine you've got your
taste
you've got your plating I forget what
the other categories are I mean you
couldn't you know have all sorts of
other categories that you build into it
as well but each one can only admit of
so much pleasure so they can't really be
accumulated as distinct different
pleasures now I can keep piling up on
top of each other and I'll eventually
reach some height of pleasure so that
you know first you start out with let's
say being in a diner and having you know
a patio right and then you say all right
I'm gonna switch it out for a gourmet
Patti melts you know made with Wagyu
beef and the special onions that some
chef caramelize it's just the right way
right because you're increasing the
intensity of pleasure there right now
it's no longer gonna be a diner it's
gonna be a beautiful restaurant
overlooking a mountain
halli so you can look down and you've
got the spectacular view and instead of
it being whatever you know radio station
is playing at the diner
it's gonna be wonderful classical music
to you know to fit the thing and and
your drink that you'll have with it will
be a perfect wine paired with it and
pick yours and say well you look nice
but you're not like piling one pleasure
on top of each other usually laying out
a whole bunch of pleasures and if you're
attending to one of them you're not
paying attention to the other one you
can only get so far with that
he also says pleasure in the body has a
limit for the intensity once pain has
been removed it only admits of
variations so there's like a certain
limit that you get to and you can't
really increase pleasure beyond that you
can just introduce new types so and this
is actually what we have to do you know
I'm gonna listen to this song and I find
this so pleasurable now imagine I'm
gonna keep playing that song over and
over again people do that when they
first buy Wow I mean now they don't
people who buy CDs anymore I think
people that I now buy albums because
they want to show how hip they are but
most people buy mp3s you get an mp3 of
your favorite band and there's this one
song you listen to it over and over
again that'll work for a while of course
you're probably driving everybody else
around you nuts that's because that's
not pleasurable for them but after a
while you gotta switch it to something
else or it's not going to be pleasant
anymore it's lost its its charm
well what about mental pleasures you can
actually increase the intensity of them
and they can sort of you know function
as a composite the other thing I want to
point out with mental pleasures there
there are two things that Epicurus
really stresses even more in the vatican
sayings than he does in the principal
doctrines or the letter 2:9 osseous that
the mental pleasures include some of the
most pleasant pleasurable things one of
these is friendship friendship is a
long-term thing you can't substitute
friendship under just a physical
pleasure it's not something just you
know available at a moment but by
definition right it's not a it's not
relationship if it only exists at one
given point in time there has to be a
kind of continuity to it and that you
can in fact build a lot of things into a
friendship including plenty of physical
pleasures he's not he's not against
physical pleasures he's just saying look
they only go so far but a friendship
itself is a pleasure of the mind you are
in relation to the other person as a
personality as somebody who has a mind
somebody with whom you can share things
now intellectual activity
Epicurus also considers very pleasurable
and he thinks that that philosophy and
this is going to be a big stretch for
many of you philosophy of something
where it's unlike many other kinds of
pleasures where you have to you know be
initiated into it and develop a certain
apart you know I'm out before you can
begin to actually feel pleasure he says
no you you start doing philosophy you'll
feel pleasure so we don't what would
that mean if you took a intro to
philosophy class and you didn't feel
pleasure but but rather mental pain
instead when your instructors doing it
wrong or they didn't give you the right
kind of philosophy if we broaden it and
we talk about learning in general
different people are interested in
different things some people are really
interested in military history they
couldn't care less about other topics
some people want to know sports dance
right and why do they want to know about
them now but you know some people are
really into that sort of thing some
people want to know everything they can
about certain kinds of flowers other
people you know there's for everybody
you pick there's something that they're
interested in and that intellectual
activity of learning about it talking
about it thinking about it that can be
intensely pleasurable and now you could
of course steer it into higher things as
well but it can be extremely pleasurable
one you know great example of this a
contemporary example if you've ever
spent you know rather lost four hours on
the internet going from site to site to
site researching something and I put
researching and scare quotes because
that's what we tell ourselves we're
doing but we're really doing is enjoying
the intellectual activity of like here's
more
this I'm interested in this I have to
admit I've done that with you know the
wiki of Ice and Fire you know with
George Martin's universe I've done that
with Wikipedia itself for classic heavy
metal bands because there's links that
you can follow out everywhere um one of
us can can relate to that sort of
activity it's a lot easier to do now
that we have the internet available
right but that's that's a pleasurable
activity and that's not subject to the
sort of constraints that merely physical
or bodily pleasures are subject to so
Epicurus is very strongly stressing the
superiority of mental pleasures again
correlative Lee is arguing the the fact
that mental pains are much more
devastating much more troubling than
merely physical pains